[Music]
here's a question for you what can
Socrates Bruce Springsteen and Steph
Curry all teach us about Parenthood well
one of the world's best-selling
philosophers explores that question in a
new book we're talking about Ryan
Holliday's book uh his other titles like
the daily stoic have sold more than 2
million copies worldwide 2 million and
his fans include Tom Brady and Katy
Perry his new book is the daily Dad
sorry Michelle 366 meditations on
parenting love and raising great kids
he's a father of two himself he offers
advice and wisdom called from historic
figures living legends pop culture and
more and Ryan holiday joins us now Ryan
thank you for being here um so you
opened the book by pointing out that
lots of people have kids but not enough
of us become parents that's a really
important Insight yep but parenting
today is different right than it was way
back when so how can we go to history to
learn something about what we're doing
now yeah by definition people came
before us or we wouldn't be here
and I think it's remarkable you know
Socrates has kids Aristotle has kids
Cleopatra has kids so many historical
figures had kids they weren't all
perfect parents but we can learn
something from them one of my favorite
Expressions is that any fool can learn
by experience you know we should learn
from the experiences of others and so I
think we look at these historical
figures and we can learn about being
present we can learn about controlling
our temper we can learn about helping
them our kids become who they're meant
to be and we can we can pick and choose
from what these historical figures did
right and we can pick and choose from
what they did wrong yeah yeah Vlad I
want to bring you in right away because
vlad's a new dad he can count for days
so as part of our series Vlad to Dad
Tony and I did a podcast and one of the
things he impressed on me which I think
about a lot which is that your children
whilst they are a part of you and your
and my wife they are their own unique
individual human beings um with unique
personalities and you have a quote by
Marcus Aurelius in the book which I love
like life is short do not forget the
most important things in life living for
other people and doing good things for
them and I thought to myself if nothing
else I don't care what she does with for
a career or what path she chooses but
this is the one that I would want her to
keep closest to her heart why is this
such an important Maxim yeah it's it's
about helping them become who they're
meant to be not who you want them to be
I heard this great distinction are you a
gardener or you uh uh an architect right
and no we're helping them become what
they're capable of being and that's what
the Stokes we're doing Marcus really has
12 children and so we see these stoics
as these philosophers and they were but
they were also dealing with wake-ups in
the middle of the night they were
dealing with rebellious teenagers
they're dealing with all the stuff that
we're dealing with and it's challenging
them in all the ways that it's
challenging us but if we want to talk
about having multi-generational impact
right we can try to do it in our but we
could also try to do it with the people
that we're raising in our homes yeah I
love books like this daily word I'm
waiting for the daily mom but you know
well I'm sure
maybe I should write the daily mom but
you know I I opened it up to May 1st and
May 1st this predicts everything
character is fate
I remember a movie I love called Simply
Irresistible and that was when she threw
at him he was like you
you've why is this one so important you
know I when we're trying to raise
successful kids there's a lot of proxies
we can look at right how are they doing
in school you know what career track are
they on if you want to raise a good kid
why don't you focus on character that
the other version of that Greek
expression is that character is Destiny
yes right the the the character that you
instill in them the virtues the values
you give them ultimately that's gonna
determine who they are the the four
stoic Birches I haven't tattooed on my
wrist here is courage discipline Justice
and wisdom and I think if you can if you
can create a home in which those four
virtues are Paramount which you are
embodying them not just talking about
them but you are yourself living them
and your kids can pick up on that
they're going to turn out okay right
they're going to turn out okay in the
long run now I think one of the biggest
stressors to parents is trying to have
the right answer all the time yeah and
you say it's better to have the right
question and I want to get your thoughts
on a couple of of them first am I
cherishing garbage time unpack that a
little bit we talk a lot about quality
time right we all want to have quality
time with our kids that's why we plan
trips I brought my kids to New York for
this right and we get here yesterday and
it's pouring rain so the plans are go
sideways but they had just as much fun
playing in the rain outside a block from
our hotel as they did whatever we could
have planned right so quality time and
in some ways is almost this cop-out
because it's in the future a garbage
time is right now every minute can be
quality time you know we think of
planning the vacation but the drive to
the airport is also part of the trip and
if you're stressed and miserable and
you're rushing through it you're giving
up what is extraordinary and wonderful
they call it the present right now
all right Ryan holiday we have to leave
it there uh the one question you say
that parents should ask their kids every
day is what good did you do for someone
else yeah silly dad goes on sale
tomorrow we'll be right back